my friends i want to show you google
take a look at this
go to google and type in silver and
reddit and you see all these top stories
silver is the new short squeeze target
for reddit traders
these market analysts blah blah blah
move over gamestop reddit traders are
targeting
silver now new york post reddit's epic
silver squeeze is only helping wall
street this is the most
brazen and insane fake news
i have ever seen i apologize to those of
you who have watched the rest of my
content
throughout the day because this is the
main thing i've been harping on in every
single video i don't really do that
sometimes i'll get
you know sometimes but this is the
craziest thing i've ever seen seriously
share this i okay look let me let me
show you this post right here from
wall street bets it is a bloom someone's
watching bloomberg
and you can see it says this woman emma
chandra of bloomberg news and then
underneath
retail traders lose interest in gamestop
that is 100 fake news
the number one post right now on i
believe the number one post on wall
street bets
why you definitely should not under any
circumstances fall for the silver scams
you are being played by the most
powerful elite on the planet
think about what they say in that new
york post article reddit's epic silver
squeeze
is only helping wall street there is no
epic silver squeeze
it doesn't exist if silver is going up
and it did earlier today
it's because the media is pumping it now
this is where things
like the i'm sorry man the veil has been
shattered
we're seeing two things right now two
things the first
they don't like that gamestop has
actually the the game stop retail
investors
are actually hurting the hedge funds
melvin capital down 53
they don't like it so what we're seeing
now is i believe this is more likely to
be some kind of standalone complex where
all these people in media
have connections they get fake stories
seated and then dumb journalists with
malicious journalists who are trying to
make a pretty penny pump out this story
to divert
everyone's attention away from gamestop
a lot of the people who are investing
are probably just someone who saw the
news
there's now eight million users on r
slash wall street bats 8 million
a good portion of them probably just
tuned in as a get-rich-quick scheme
not all of them not most but just a lot
right i think what we're seeing is that
these these special interests these
elites are trying to convince people
go buy dogecoin go buy go buy silver but
we're seeing something else
more nefarious than ever we are seeing
exactly why wall street bets is doing
what they're doing
we are seeing the crony machine in play
they are lying to you to get you to buy
silver
so they can pump the price of silver up
then all of their friends will
sell out when silver peaks leave you
holding an
empty bag they do it all the time and
they're doing it in our face
right now now it's not not just the new
york post there it's also cnbc that has
this headline
silver jumps eight percent touches eight
year high
as reddit traders try their squeeze play
with the metal and when you look at the
media coverage it definitely kind of
changed it was always sinister it was
always extremely negative towards
redditors towards
the plebes or peasants who are actually
gaining some
financial uh wisdom and outsmarting the
wall street guys it was always negative
towards them because they're not
part of the in club they're not part of
the establishment but
but we have to understand it's always
coming from the same kind of point of
view it's
always coming from the same kind of
perspective washington post wrote an
opinion piece about
the hedge funds being the good guys we
have msnbc
literally had an anchor on there talking
about how the redditch traders
are going to be self-harming themselves
like instagram women who are depressed
that they're going to start cutting
themselves because they're wasting their
time
i'm not kidding you it's absolutely
bonkers and absolutely just
insane the coverage we're seeing by
msnbc and then of course we also had
jimmy kimmel on oh yeah television
to the national public talking about
these amateur investors
who are maybe influenced by russia
literally russian bots yes russian
development russian it was
exactly what he said but look at the
obfuscation look at the manipulation
look at the disinformation propaganda
campaign
used against individuals the plebes who
are finally playing in the stock market
by the rules of the hedge funds and the
hedge funds and establishment are saying
wait wait wait we can only win this game
not you when they're playing by the
rules fairly
it's absolutely insane it's it's
borderline criminal
there if we lived in a fair system and
there was justice in this world
there would be some serious criminal
charges but there's not janet yellen
i mean she's on the take here obviously
getting paid in my opinion
in my opinion she's on the take but but
she's getting paid hundreds of thousands
of dollars from these companies these
companies have a revolving door within
the u.s federal reserve
ben bernanke is also involved in citadel
i mean you could name the list of
government officials that just go from
one day public representatives
of you to selling you out the next day
and it's absolutely sickening what's
going on here and guess what
it's only going to get a lot worse this
is i
i was left dumbfounded this morning but
this is a good sign though but this is
this is how they're panicking nailed the
bale was shattered exactly this is a
great sign because look how
desperate they're becoming that they're
literally you know going at the straws
here being like
silver silver now i personally like
silver i even made a video
two weeks ago saying hey i even
interviewed someone in the silver
business and i was like i personally
like silver as an alternative to the
dollar
not financial advice uh just my own
personal opinion but even now
when you look at the top reddit post and
you look at what people are saying
they're saying
wait wait wait there's no short on
silver a lot of hedge funds do
own silver as well and they make good
good points there that really are worth
considering well here
here's the interesting thing uh well
actually before i get it let me say this
silver is fantastic silver i love silver
just not when it's being pumped and
dumped
when's when all the media is claiming
fake something fake is happening like
all these redditors are telling you to
buy silver they're not
the price of silver skyrockets you buy
in when when silver is at thirty dollars
and then you're all excited and then the
hedge funds who are seeking to offset
their losses
sell out huge portions of silver at a
market at a premium
from your money then when silver tanks
the regular people panic not
understanding the market losing all of
that money
and then wall street absorbs it all buys
back the silver they gave out in the
first place
and makes that money they make money on
top and they get the silver back at the
same time
that's the game that's the manipulation
so how do you think they'll pump it
i don't know some people are posting
like it's going to hit 500
oh maybe i've seen some interesting
posts where they say dude
in reality silver should be way higher
yeah you were saying they artificially
keep the price low so that's what
they're saying online they're saying
that these companies
you know like if people if silver
tracked with inflation exactly higher
yeah it's been like 16 bucks for a
decade
for decades here's the really
interesting and important thing about
what's going on
is that they're not telling people to
buy physical silver they're telling them
to buy
slv that's where it's at which is that's
what i i think that's silver futures i'm
not entirely sure please no buy actual
silver i'm not an investment strategist
but
buying stock in something is very you
know ian ian is a is a is a crazy hippie
guy in the internet don't listen to him
you can rub it on your neck you can
stick it on your third eye that's what i
do with my gold
don't you drink it like you put in your
drinks yeah it's anti-microbial
antibiotics put in their clothes you
ever see the silver clothing it's great
no but i hear it's great for you that's
why there was
always the the term born with a silver
spoon in his mouth you can brush your
teeth
a lot of people believe that silver you
know has anti-bacterial anti-viral
properties you can rub it in wood and it
kills werewolves yeah it kills
i heard a lot of people saying they're
trying to get people to buy
slv um and not physical silver but if
everyone tried buying physical silver it
would seriously squeeze out
all of the all of the the actual
physical bullion stores and everything
which could actually have a serious
impact because
apparently the banks won't be able to
cover if people actually want it so i
don't look i'm not gonna pretend to be a
stock guy i'm just gonna tell you this
i'm a media guy i know how the media
lies i know the games they play so don't
get advice for me i want you to with
stock
for me this is about the overlap between
the the wall street bets redditors and
what they're actually saying
and me being a critic of the media and
trying to expose them in their
manipulation and now seeing how you got
a bunch of the little
it's the little guy this dude deep
effing value
who's now become a multi-millionaire off
of his you know his bets
he's just some dad in like the
massachusetts area he is not the machine
but now he's in the top point what was
he 0.1 percent now
net worth is like 30 something million
dollars
dude there are ceos who who don't make
that much money in a year and he's made
it in six months
doing what what did he how did he make
it yeah investing in gamestop wow
that's right because it was at like five
bucks and that's at 300 wow
so a message very serious increase in
all of your money
and he's posting you know his yolo
updates and it's like 20 million
percent 20 million dollars up thousands
of percent
they don't like that you're not allowed
to be in the club we talked about this
with bernie sanders a while back
how bernie sanders used to say the
millionaires and the billionaires in
this country
and then one day he stopped saying stop
saying the millionaires one day he
became a millionaire exactly he sold a
book
yup so the book became a millionaire and
now he doesn't say it anymore
and that's insane because you still can
not someone but also
also we've talked about this before i
think the millionaires really aren't the
problem maybe if you're like 998 million
not dude even someone who has 200
million 200 million they can
they can someone that's worth 2.3
million dollars isn't
right yeah so why bernie sanders dropped
that is beyond me but that's that's
i don't want to get off on tangent on
bernie just yet we have some stuff on
barney for later
the media media's smearing him what i'm
saying is bernie was standing outside
that mansion
the clubhouse with all the elites and
all the re the wealthy you know people
and he was outside and he was like oh i
want to be inside there with the
millionaires and the billionaires oh the
millionaires and the billionaires are
awful
screw them it was sour grapes you can't
beat them join them but then one day
they open the door and they say bernie
come on in you can be one of us and now
he stops saying the millionaires
because they let him in the club this
dude deep effing value on wall street
bets is not part of the club
and so now he's somehow found his way
inside this building and they're pissed
off
they're looking over they're all wearing
their fancy suits pinkies out with their
and their monocles and they see this
dude with a red bandana on
who sell who bought a bunch of game stop
stock and it reminds me of like i played
a poker game once
and i literally had no idea what i was
doing because that was when i was like
18.
and i hell i i i kept i kept uh betting
more
and i was holding two seven off suit and
i ended up winning
because the last dude folded and he was
really angry
and then i showed what i had and he
started screaming and yelling well you
shouldn't have hold he should have
folded i should have won
and i was like i played better i guess
no it was just dumb luck i had no idea i
had the worst possible hand
and so now you have these people who are
in the club who have who have
sold their souls who have dropped to
their knees and given everything to be
in that club
and this dude walks in with this bandana
on and he's like i don't know i just
bought a stock that was probably not
supposed to go up and i screwed the
hedge fund it's like that eddie murphy
movie from the 80s what was it called
uh trading places was that what it was
yeah trading places i think where he
became the rich guy yeah i like it
yeah yeah yeah so they they they give
the the bunk information to the
these big investors and then screw them
over he and dan aykroyd is it
they switched yeah murphy and danny oh
great dan aykroyd is this like
a rich wall street trader and he's like
snooty and eddie murphy's a homeless guy
and they make a bet and they switch him
to see if they can like
make it work or whatever it's a great
movie by the way time to watch that
movie
i definitely want to watch it that's
that's a really fun movie people are
posting that
like as a like me yeah yeah yeah that's
why it was on my mind i guess yeah
uh did max kaiser just a few years ago
call for buying silver to squeeze out jp
morgan
he's he's he's saying he's saying i
think max is tweeting now to do it
yeah i'm looking at what max is doing
now i'm going to look at his twitter
account just to see because he he's also
a big silver guy he's a big alternatives
guy to the us dollar
so it'll be interesting to see what he
says i remember
seeing a lot of silver news with him
just a few years ago about this
specifically
listen listen i i like max he's a very
smart guy
but he's also he's a he's a crypto guy
he's a bitcoin guy
and i wonder if his perspective on it is
what they're doing the hedge funds won't
break the system it'll break the hedge
funds
and crypto will break the system so
that's why he's you know telling
everybody
you got to go after crypto short the
whole you know short squeeze the whole
system
but i will say you know maybe max is
right far be it for me to criticize that
guy that you know for those aren't
familiar max kaiser is he's been in the
game
for longer than i've been alive and
there was a funny video he posted from
like 1987 of him ragging on yuppies and
i'm like dude i was pr i wasn't i was
like one
so uh respect respect to max what i can
say is the redditors are saying here's
our mission
and so what we're seeing now with all of
this it's this is very similar what
happens with any semi-decentralized mass
movement
we saw with occupy wall street the first
one a lot of people were like yo we're
met at the banks and then also a bunch
of people came up and started screaming
about non-really unrelated issues
i remember i was down at occupy wall
street and they were having a meeting
over what their main demand should be
well everybody was there because the big
bank bailouts
and the the the gambling they did that
destroyed the market destroyed evans
livelihood
and i remember one one day while they're
having this meeting with like a ton of
people
some guy just like old white dude
randomly stood up and screamed
what is wrong with you people fracking
is the problem it's the center of
everything and i'm like what does
fracking have to do with the banks
but in his mind everything because he
couldn't see
past his own desire and demands so now
you're seeing a lot of people posting
now is our chance everybody buy dogecoin
why so they can get
get rich off dogecoin buying those
credits doesn't hurt anybody and
what happens is when the price of
dosecoin collapses because there's no
demand or interest then people get left
holding an empty bag
but what they're doing with with
gamestop and amc
and bed bath and beyond and american
airlines these were the short targets
so now these hedge funds are going to
lose money what they're doing has an
impact
but a bunch of people saw that power
they saw all of these people
shining their lights in a single
direction creating a massive you know
effect
and they said if only i could point that
in the direction i want i could have
more power
so everyone's trying to now wield the
power of wall street bets for themselves
we're seeing twitter accounts pop up
with the image claiming like
they're part of the movement or speak
you know in some way for it
we're seeing different reddits pop up
saying very similar things but there is
an overall unity for the most part like
there's a majority or
a majority of people saying gamestop amc
those are the targets yeah well the
movement's biggest strength is also its
biggest weakness
because it is decentralized you don't
really see a big rallying call you do
see a lot of censorship
you do see a lot of obfuscation by the
mainstream media but it's also a bunch
of people being like hey
and a bunch of noise so it's very hard
to kind of organize that into one big
vocal
uh kind of representation here so it
could be just disorganized chaos that
happened organically or it could be
pushed on and spurred on by some other
elites who
of course are benefiting off of people
being fractured and divided and
conquered
both are possible here thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time